PROFESSOR: All right, let's
resume our discussion.
And we'll finish it for sure
by the end of today.
And as you say, you can tuck
this away for study on your
own or for future reference or
whatever you want to do.
So if we could assign sizes to
atoms and ions, we could do a
lot towards predicting what sort
of structures they might
form if we knew the
composition.
The composition--
again, assuming there is only
one type of anion and one type
of cation, the composition is
determined by the valence.
The composition fixes the ratio
of coordination numbers.
And the structure will have
lowest energy when we have the
maximum number of anions around
cation and vice-versa.
So we're in great shape.
And this is simple, idealized,
but very powerful stuff if we
knew the sizes that were
assumed by ions.
And that, really, is an absurd
notion, to talk about an atom
as though it behaved like a
sphere with finite dimensions.
If we plotted the density of the
electrons as a function of
distance R from an atom, it
does something like this.
At very small distances, that
defines a shell of a rather
small volume, so there are
not many electrons.
Rises up to a maximum, and
then tails off gradually.
So what is the radius?
The maximum in the distribution
of density.
So the notion of radius is
absolutely nonsense in terms
of the actual distribution
of electrons on the atom.
However, one can get from your
fraction measurements a
determination of the
lattice constant.
And even with routine methods,
you can get the dimension of
the lattice to extraordinary
precision.
The typical lattice constant
is about 10 Angstroms.
You can get this through routine
methods to plus or
minus 1 in the fourth
decimal point.
So this is a precision of
1 part in 10 to the 5th.
You can get atomic positions
when they are not fixed by
symmetry to get a coordinate to
plus or minus 0.yyyy plus
or minus 1 in good cases.
So that is 1 part in
10 to the 5th.
Missing a factor or
10 somewhere.
This is plus or minus 1.
That's 1 in 10 to the 4th.
So you can get this information
very accurately.
One thing I always like to
point out here is that a
thermal expansion coefficient
for most inorganic materials
is something that never gets
much lower than about 1 or 2
times 10 to the minus 6.
So if you're going to push the
measurement of a lattice
constant to the ultimate
accuracy, you'd better have a
thermometer on the top of the
X-ray generator, or your
measurement is meaningless.
The thermal expansion can be
more than the uncertainty in
your measurement.
So you should report, for very
precise measurements, the
temperature at which you
made your measurement.
OK, you can get interionic
distances with very high
precisions.
And if you look at a series
of compounds--
and these are the ones that are
discussed in the notes,
which have the rock salt
structure type.
So here is the cation,
here is the anion.
The anion-cation distance is
simply equal to 1/2 of A for
the rock salt structure.
So that's easy.
You don't even have to know
the atomic positions.
Just measure the lattice
constants.
And then you would find, for
example, that R, NA plus R, CL
is equal to 1/2 of A for NaCl.
Very precisely know the sum.
How do we split this up?
Well, let's look at
another compound.
Let's look at R, NA plus
R for bromine.
And that would be 1/2 of the
lattice constant of NaBr.
Hm.
More data, but we haven't
solved anything.
We have three radii, only
two measurements.
And you can see, if you try to
push this further, you can
never get enough information
to split up the interionic
distances into sums of
individual radii in any sort
of unique fashion.
So you have to start
somewhere.
And there are different sets
of ionic radii that were
proposed early in the game.
And they are discussed
in the notes.
I give you an example of some
of the sums of radii for the
oxides and sulfides
and selenides of
the transition metals.
You can see that as the anion
atomic number increases, the
size of the lattice
constant goes up.
So you could get, for example,
the difference in size between
a sulfur and an oxygen and the
difference in radius between a
selenium and a sulfur.
But you could never get
the absolute values.
There are four early
sets of radii.
And they are tabulated for you
part way through the notes.
And there's a cautionary
lesson here.
One the early series
of radii--
see, even the old workers in
this field appreciated the
role of ionic sizes in
determining structure.
So they wanted to set up
self-consistent schemes of radii.
And the earliest one is by,
really, the founder of crystal
chemistry, a man named
Goldschmidt.
Linus Pauling got into the
act very early on.
If you look at this table that
I copied from these separate
publications, four different
people--
Goldschmidt, Pauling, Zacharias
and Ahrens.
Some people left out the radii
of certain species.
Other people left out different
radii depending on
the compounds that
they looked at.
If people looked at the same
ion, they very often got very,
very different values,
depending on
their starting point.
Look at the size of barium,
for example.
Zacharias said 1.29.
Ahrens said 1.34.
Pauling said 1.35.
Goldschmidt said 1.43.
Depends on the starting
point that they used
for the initial radius.
And once you've determined
that,
everything falls into place.
Another basis for determining
radii, Bragg determined a
number of the structure of
important silicates.
Why silicates?
Because as you walk
along the ground,
you're walking on silicates.
These are part of the minerals
that form the Earth's crust,
so there was a lot of
interest in those.
Bragg, from his early work way
back in the late 1920s, found
that the size and shape of the
Si04 tetrahedron forms
tetrahedral coordination because
silicon is so small
compared to oxygen.
The interionic distances were
always about the same.
The tetrahedron was
always regular.
So what Bragg said was, a-ha,
this is a tough little nut in
silicate structures.
Doesn't deform.
The size is always the same.
It's always regular.
The reason must be that the
oxygens are just in contact.
So he used the dimensions of an
Si04 tetrahedron, took the
radius of oxygen as
half the edge.
Pauling used a different
starting point
that has been followed.
There's still another way
of determining radii.
Is there any physical property
of a material which might also
be shown to be proportional
to the size of the ion?
And the answer to that,
which I'll pass
over quickly, is yes.
Quantity called the ionic
electrical polarizability,
which is the relation between an
applied electric field and
the dipole moment that is
induced on the atom when you
separate the electron cloud
and the nucleus.
And a simple model shows--
and this is carried
out for you--
that you can relate the ionic
electronic polarizability to
the volume of the atom, and it
turns out to be beautifully
simple, that the polarizability
is simply 4 pi
epsilon 0 times the radius
of the ion cubed.
So therefore, you can split up
ionic radii in proportion to
the cube root of the
polarizability of the ions.
Well, that trades one
problem for another.
How do you get polarizabilities?
It turns out that the index of
refraction of materials is
given by the sum of the number
of each species per unit
volume times the ionic
polarizability of that species.
And there is a famous
equation called the
Lorentz-Lorenz equation.
I can never resist calling
it not the Lorenz-Lorentz
equation but the Lorenz-Lorentz
equation
equation because it
sounds like you're
saying everything twice.
If you note that the dielectric
constant of a
material is related to the
square of the index of
refraction, instead of n
squared, you can replace the n
squared by epsilon, the
dielectric constant, and then
the equations become
known as the
Clausius-Mossotti equations.
And I always take that as a nice
illustration of the fact
that a very simple change of
variables can be all it takes
to become famous and immortal.
[INAUDIBLE]
what happened to Clausius
and Mossotti.
Where do you get
polarizabilities from?
This was looked at by
a number of people.
One of the most complete were
three people, Tessman, Kahn,
and Wild Bill Shockley
of transistor fame.
So you can find these numbers,
and you can get a
self-consistent set of radii.
But note in the table that
I give you here that the
individual numbers are
very different.
And two caveats that I have to
issue is you can't mix ionic
radii in different people's
tables because they have
different starting assumptions
for the standard radius.
If you do that, you're mixing
apples and oranges.
And I wish I had a cookie for
every half-baked book on
chemistry that said, hey, Ahrens
has got something for
americium and Pauling doesn't.
Let me put the value for
americium in there.
Totally wrong that they
are established
on different bases.
So you can't mix apples
and oranges.
You have to use a
self-consistent set of radii.
The ones that were followed
until very recently are
Pauling's radii.
And Pauling's radii are based
on a standard radius for
oxygen, which is 1.40
Angstroms for
the radius of oxygen.
The other thing that I have to
issue as a caveat, which I
hope you won't forget, is that
radius ratios do a pretty good
job of predicting the expected
coordination number.
But if you are very, very close
to a limiting critical
radius ratio, all
bets are off.
Because then you're really
asking the question, if I have
this polyhedron of ions, if I
squish them a little bit so
that I increase the coordination
number, does that
give me a lower energy in return
for the price that I
have to pay to deform the ions
that I'm packing together?
And that is not possible to
answer on the basis of a rigid
sphere model.
So when you're very close to a
critical radius ratio, you
really can't say for sure
whether the structure will go
to the lower coordination
number or the higher
coordination number.
So you have to be
careful of that.
Finally, people have
continued on.
And stuck in the margin of
these older radii is a
reference to a paper by two
people, Bob Shannon, who was a
crystallographer at DuPont,
and Charlie Prewitt.
I'm very proud that he became so
notable, because he was my
office mate in graduate
school.
So I like to promote his
radii whenever I can.
And in Acta Crystallographica in
1969, they published a set
of radii, which is in the nice
typeset version that's Xeroxed
directly from their paper in
Acta Crystallographica.
And the headings need
explanation.
There's the ion and its valence,
then the electron
configuration.
And what's interesting is that
some of the transition metals,
for example iron, can be in
a high-spin or a low-spin
configuration depending on
whether the moments on the
electrons are all parallel
or anti-parallel.
High-spin and low-spin
configurations give ions with
very, very distinct radii.
So the second column, EC,
stands for Electron
Configuration.
Then comes coordination
number.
And here is another feature
that we really should not
overlook, that as even
rigid spheres--
here's an A, and here's a B--
acquire progressively higher
coordination numbers--
let's look at just coordination
number three and
coordination number four,
because they're easy to draw.
In addition to the attractive
force between anion and
cation, there is also
a repulsive
force between the anions.
So here's the repulsive force
between this B and its
neighboring B and this B and
its neighboring B. And the
resultant is a force that
tends to push apart
the A and the B ion.
For four-coordination, remember
first of all, the Bs
are closer, so the repulsive
force is stronger.
But there are four
of them, as well.
So this turns out to be a
larger repulsive force.
So the conclusion is that the
radius of A would be expected
to go up slightly as the
coordination number increased,
simply because there is a
repulsive interaction between
the coordinating Bs.
And that will tend to push them
apart more strongly as
the coordination goes up.
So the third column in the
Shannon and Prewitt tables is
coordination number.
And if you look at several
ions, they're--
for example, barium has
6-coordination,
7-coordination.
8, 9, 10, and even 12.
And as you go down that list
of radii, it gets larger as
the coordination goes up.
And it's a relatively small
effect that's on the order of
5 or so percent.
But still, when trying to
calculate an interionic
distance, you should use the
radius that is appropriate for
the coordination numbers.
The fourth column is spin.
And the spin stands for
high spin or low spin.
And you will find that for the
transition metal atoms--
for example, CO2 plus low spin
or high spin, and note the
rather different radii for these
two configurations of
the electron moments.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Under coordination
number, what's the difference
between 4SQ and just Q?
PROFESSOR: You would guess
that the lowest energy
configuration for
four-coordination would be
tetrahedral, because
that keeps the
anions most widely separated.
There are cases where the
coordination is plainer.
So the "SQ" stands for square,
and that's unusual.
And you'll notice that that
appears for things like
silver, which has a considerable
covalent
character to it.
For gold, 3-plus.
That's one of the noble metals,
again, that has a
considerable covalent
character to it.
So you'll notice that as the
coordination number goes up,
you get a different radius.
Now, there are then a set of
numbers, and these are numbers
that are based on different
starting points.
The furthest column to the
right, quote "IR" quote, this
is based on Pauling's
starting point.
And Pauling's starting point,
if you go way down the list
onto the second page, is that
for 02 minus for oxygen in
six-coordination, the standard
radius from which everything
else hinges is 1.40.
The Pauling radii had been so
commonly used that Shannon and
Prewitt decided to use 1.40,
Pauling's radii.
So all of their numbers are
compatible with the early
Pauling radii, except they're
based on thousands more
crystal structure
determinations.
There is another column,
second from the
right, called CR.
And that stands for
Crystal Radii.
And there were two people that
proposed that Pauling's radii
really didn't give a feel for
the proper sizes of the ions.
And they went on at great
length to explain what
"proper sizes" is.
And the only difference for the
sizes that are based on,
quote, "crystal radii" is that
if you go all the way down to
oxygen, the size of the oxygen
ion in six-coordination is
given by 1.26.
So all of the anions in the
crystal radius column are
smaller by 1.40 minus 1.26.
I can do that in my head.
That's 0.14 Angstroms.
Run down the list.
They're 1.4 Angstroms smaller
for the anions.
And the cations are 0.14
Angstroms larger.
So there are two alternative
sets of radii, one based on
the traditional Pauling radii,
1.40 for oxygen in
six-coordination, and the
Fumi-Tosi radii, 1.26, which
maybe give a better picture
of what the sphere sizes
actually, quote, "look
like," unquote.
But note the tendencies.
There is a progressive
change--
whoever's starting point you
use, there's a progressive
change in size with coordination
number.
And let me give you, if I may,
at this point, give you--
again, a little knowledge
is a dangerous thing.
One of the structures which I
worked on many years ago was a
puzzle, and this was the
prototype fast ion conductor
silver iodide.
And nobody had been able to
determine the structure for
several reasons.
Nobody had ever made a single
crystal of it, and all the
diffraction data you had
available for the structure
were five or six intensities.
And there were about seven
parameters necessary to fully
describe the structure, so
you were out of luck.
We learned how to make
single crystals.
But before that--
no, he will go nameless.
He said, OK, let's see
what's going on here.
Oh, we'll get the radius
of silver.
We know that in silver iodide,
the iodines are in
body-centered cubic packing.
And we know what the lattice
constant is, because we got
that from powder diffraction
data.
Huh, the silver ion is too
big to fit in either the
tetrahedral interstitial site or
the octahedral interstitial
site in silver iodide.
So he said, therefore, the
structure has to distort, and
it's really tetragonal.
But there are going
to be domains.
a tetragonal domain in one
orientation here, a tetragonal
domain in another orientation
here.
So he gets himself a random
number generator and takes
numbers one, two, and three and
puts it on a cubic lattice
to determine what the
distortion will be.
Said, hey, I got a bunch of
ones here and a bunch of
threes here.
This crystal is built
of domains.
And the reason the silver ions
migrate rapidly is that a
domain can pop from one mode of
distortion to another, and
that's essentially going to
transport the silver ion from
one end of the domain
to another.
This guy got two papers
out of it.
What he had done was he looked
up the radius of silver in
Pauling's tables.
And he didn't realize that all
of Pauling's original radii
were normalized to octahedral
six-hole coordination, which
makes the radius larger.
And that's why the silvers
didn't fit in any of the
interstices.
If you take the tetrahedral
radius for silver, which is
where it actually sits in the
structure, it fits as snugly
and nicely as you please in the
tetrahedral interstitial
site in the body-centered
cubic arrangement.
So this guy made an idiot of
himself because he didn't
realize the basis on which
these tables had been
established.
But he's nameless, so I
can call him names.
So anyway, again, a little
knowledge can
be a dangerous thing.
Moving on, in the few minutes
that we have left to devote to
crystal chemistry.
Pauling's radii, and even
better still now, the
Shannon-Prewitt radii, let you
predict nearest-neighbor
configurations--
coordination numbers with fair
degree of confidence.
Pauling--
and this was one of the things
that he received the Nobel
Prize for--
proposed a set of five rules
that are called Pauling's
Rules for ionic structure.
The first thing he said was
something that we've already
stated, a coordination polyhedra
of anions is formed
about each cation, and the
cation-anion distance is
determined by the sum of the
radii, and the coordination
number is determined
by radius ratio.
So there are three principles
in here.
The two most important ones is
that expressing faith in a set
of radii to determine interionic
distances and the
fact that if there are radii
that can be assigned to the
atoms, you can predict a
coordination number.
So that's Pauling's
first rule.
Actually, Pauling's first
rule was first stated by
Goldschmidt.
But to have a complete listing
of guiding principles, he
included that there and didn't
claim it was his own.
But then he does something that
is rather interesting.
This is the only one of the
rules that is quantitative.
If you had an ionic structure,
and you could determine its
unit cell, the structure should
be electrically neutral
if it's composed of ions
that are charged.
So therefore, you would not make
a structure in which all
the cations were up in one
corner of the cell, and all
the anions were down in the
opposite end of the cell.
That would be something that
might be electrically neutral,
but it would be a high-energy
configuration.
So Pauling's second rule is a
very cute way of expressing
the fact that a structure
should be atomistically
electrically neutral, as well
as microscopically.
And he did that in the
following way.
He said, let us look at the
coordination number the
cation, A, and look at the
coordination polyhedron.
And let's define as the bond
strength, S, as the ratio of
the cation charge plus Q divided
by the coordination
number of A.
And then he said that in a
stable structure, if we look
at the anion, the sum of all
the bonds donated to--
he visualize the charge being
donated to the anion.
The sum of all of the bonds from
the same cations or from
different cations, if that's the
nature of the structure,
should be equal to the
charge of the anion.
So let me say "cation" here.
So it's a cute way of
expressing local
electroneutrality.
Actually, that's been superseded
by an extension of
this general principle.
And I may not have time to
discuss it today, but I'll
give you a handout next time.
It's not in the notes, either.
This is a relatively recent tool
that most people are not
familiar with, so I'll return
to it briefly next time.
The next rule says, OK, we
know how to determine the
coordination numbers.
To describe the structure, we
should be able to say how
these coordination polyhedra
fit together.
So looking at the coordination
numbers--
well, let me do a
three-dimensional case,
because that's the realistic
situation.
Let's suppose we have
coordination number eight,
which we often do.
And besides, that's
easy to draw.
So he says that in a stable
structure, the coordination
polyhedra tend to
share corners.
And I might say also that they
tend to have the line between
cation, anion, cation to be a
straight line, as opposed to
sharing edges.
So for eight-coordination, this
might be a pair of cubic
coordination polyhedra
sharing edges.
And especially corner sharing
is more favorable
than sharing faces.
It's a very specific statement
on how the coordination groups
whose geometry is determined by
size should fit together in
a structure.
And it has a very
simple basis, an
almost trivial basis.
As the polyhedra of the given
size share corners and then
edges and then faces, the
cations inside of these
polyhedra are progressively
getting
closer and closer together.
And clearly, that increases
the repulsive energy.
So the cations are most widely
separated if not faces, not
edges, but corners tend
to be shared.
Puckered a little bit.
Maybe this is not exactly
a 180-degree bond angle.
But corner sharing is
still favorable.
And rule D is essentially an
appendix to that, and it says,
and how, if the charge of the
cation is high and the
coordination number is low, the
higher the charge of the
cations, the stronger that
repulsive interaction.
The smaller the coordination
number of the cation, the
closer together they become in,
let's say, face sharing
for tubes as opposed to face
sharing for tetrahedra.
The lower the coordination
number, the closer together
the cations come, regardless
of the precise shape of the
coordination polyhedra.
So rule D says, and how for
high charge and low
coordination number.
The last rule, sometimes
called the "rule of
parsimony," the "rule of
stinginess," says that the
number of different kinds
of atoms in a
structure tends to be small.
You can read in two different
interpretations of the term
"different kinds of cations,"
and both of them are right.
You could mean different
in terms of
different chemical species.
In other words, if you take
a pot and dump half of the
elements in the periodic table
into the pot, melt it up, and
then cool it down to crystallize
the phase, you're
not going to incorporate
all of those ions
into one crystal structure.
They have different sizes.
They have different coordination
polyhedra.
The different coordination
polyhedra
have different sizes.
So to try to fit all of those
things together in one
structure is just going to
cost you a lot of energy.
It's going to be much more
efficient to form two or more
phases, which have much lower
energy, and then pay the price
of an interface between them.
So have a chemically complex
melt or solution, you're going
to get different phases.
You want to incorporate
everything into one structure.
The other interpretation of
different is in terms of their
coordination number and their
coordination polyhedra.
If the size is such that a
particular cation wants to
have tetrahedral coordination,
you would expect them all to
have tetrahedral coordination
and not have a mixture of
cubes and tetrahedra
and octahedra.
If it works for one coordination
through the
chemical species, it'll
work for them all.
That rule tends to have some,
but not terribly many,
exceptions.
But there are cases where
you find two different
coordination numbers.
But very often, that's because
of a covalent character.
So there's some discussion
and elaboration of
each of those rules.
I'm just about out of
time, and therefore
out of crystal chemistry.
Another entirely different
approach to structure is to
say that the anions are
the big things.
And if the energy of the
structure is lowered by taking
ions of like charge and getting
them as close as
possible to the larger ions,
say the anions of opposite
charge, there is a strategy for
making the arrangement.
And I think it's the same
strategy that I use when I'm
packing a suitcase for a trip.
Take the big things--
the books, the shoes--
and arrange them
in the suitcase
as densely as possible.
Then I take the little things--
the toothbrush, the
socks, and so on--
and I stick them into the
interstices that are left.
And this other view of examining
structures and
interpreting says
the same thing.
Take the big things--
not the shoes but the anions--
and arrange them as densely
as possible.
And this gets into
the question of
close packing of spheres.
Then take the little guys, the
tiny little cations, and stuff
them into the holes that
are left in the
close-packed arrays.
So another way of interpreting
structures and predicting
structures is to look at the
sort of interstices that exist
in a close-packed array.
Regardless of the stacking
sequence of spheres, there are
always two kinds of interstitial
sites, one
tetrahedral, one octahedral.
And there are two common, but
not exclusive, types of
packing arrangements, which
you probably know.
There is the cubic close
packed array.
There's a little diagram of
close-packed sheets here.
And there are two sorts of
interstices shown in the
figure on the first page
of the notes on packing
considerations.
There's one set of triangles
that points in one orientation
that forms a hollow in which
you can drop down a second
layer of spheres, another
triangle that is the closest
triangle to the first
one that points in
the opposite direction.
Each represents a potential
location for the next
close-packed sheet, but those
two different locations are
too close together
to both be used.
So you have to pick
one or another.
And if you label those three
different locations A, B, and
C, any arrangement of spheres
that does not place two
letters in succession will
give you a close-packed
arrangement with exactly
the same density.
So ABC AC, AC, ABC, AC, AC is
a packing of close-packed
spheres that is exactly the same
density as AB, AB, which
is hexagonal close packed, or
ABC, ABC, ABC, which could be
shown to be the face-centered
cubic structure.
So that is another way of
looking at structures.
And specifying the space
filling in simple ionic
structures is another way of
looking at structures.
And at that point, I'll quit.
There are some examples of
close-packed structures and
derivatives thereof that
form the last pictures.
And I'm going to stop and suck
in air and mention as one last
thought that only five
of Pauling's
rules are stated here.
There was a sixth Pauling's
rule, and that's
not commonly listed.
And I'll tell you what it is.
The sixth rule says, massive
doses of vitamin C can cure
the common cold.
Actually, that was something
that Pauling pushed.
And interestingly, about three
years before he passed away,
Pauling came to MIT and gave
a lecture in 6120.
And as you might expect of MIT
undergraduates, after he
finished his lecture, there
were a few questions.
But there were about a dozen
students who came up with
bottles of vitamin C and
asked Pauling to
autograph them for them.
And he did so with good humor
and thought he had perhaps won
a few converts in the process.
So that's it.
Getting silly, so it's time
for all of us to go home.